now to more major news from that
southern border now in recent weeks the
state of Texas they finally at a mere
necessity had to take total control of a
public park this is one an Eagle pass
that served as a very key entry point
for waves of illegal immigrants Joe
Biden unvetted illegal immigrants now
around the 10 million Mark for three
long years Joe Biden has refused to
secure this location or almost any other
location along our Southern border uh
we're now as I said approaching 10
million illegal unvetted Biden
immigrants pouring into Texas and then
of course being distributed free
Transportation by Joe Biden more than
the entire population of Dallas now
going to city and states that frankly
have no idea what to do with these
people and few by the way have undergone
any uh certainly not proper security
vetting no health screening uh all
requiring your public uh assistance
dollars this is a crisis that impacts
and affects every single corner of the
country but it's the most severe in
border states so Governor Greg Abbott
well they're not going to enforce the
law he had to take matters into his own
hands as he should and he declared a
disaster which it is he deployed State
Police the National Guard to secure the
Texas border he booted the feds out of
Shelby Park in Eagles pass they weren't
doing their job he ordered the
installation of new barriers and razor
wire to deter illegal Crossings so how
did the Biden Administration thank Texas
for their effort to do their job for
them and secure the Border they sued
Texas now this is the same Joe Biden you
know Vladimir Putin can shoot down our
drones no consequences invade Ukraine H
not a lot of consequences President
Chief spy balloons unfair Trade
Practices uh intellectual property theft
confronting our air force in in
international Airways our Navy and
international Waterway ways the m in
Iran walk all over Joe what does he do
nothing all of a sudden now your
president wants to act tough because
he's dealing with the state of Texas
because the governor is doing Joe's job
that the governor is upholding the law
that Governor Abbott is trying to secure
the Border in his State and enforce the
laws of our country to keep not only his
citizens St safe but all of us and Biden
suing the state over a new law enabling
local law enforcement to arrest best
illegal immigrants in this country and
he even sued Texas over the installation
of razor wire at the border and what was
that insane 54 decision the US Supreme
Court ruled that the Federal Government
Can can take down the wire however if
you look at that ruling they didn't
prohibit Texas from putting it up so now
Abbott has ordered the installation of
even more razor wire and the court by
the way did not give an opinion on
Abbott's decision to boot the federal
government out of Shelby Park so now
we're going to have a a law enforcement
bizarre Showdown which is now underway
between Abbott and Texas they want to
enforce the law secure the Border versus
Biden and the federal government the
ones that have encouraged lawlessness
and Asylum abuse the very people that
have been aiding and abetting those
people breaking the law allowing
unvetted people from all over the world
into our country and Abbott by the way
is not standing alone we got to give a
big shout out a lot of Republican
Governors now from 25 states have signed
a resolution supporting Texas Virginia
governor Glenn yunan tweeting quote
Virginia stands with Texas governor
Abbott is doing the job Joe Biden and
his borders are that's a joke refus to
do uh Governor Sarah Sanders Arkansas
President Biden won't defend US states
will have to defend themselves Ohio Ohio
Governor Mike dwine quote the Biden
administration's policy has been a total
failure we need change now I support
Texas uh and I support Governor Abbott
Florida Governor Ronda santis also
standing firmly behind Texas
watch Biden is going after Texas saying
that they must remove fortifications
from their border they put wire they put
things to keep people out uh Biden
saying you got to take that down to let
people come in illegally which is just
crazy and I remark that if the
Constitution was was originally
understood to mean that a state could
not protect itself against an invasion
that the federal government could force
a state to allow an invasion the
Constitution would have never been
ratified in the first place so you have
Texas here uh that's holding its ground
they have every right to fortify the
Border Visa V an invasion and that's
Article 1 Section 10 of the Constitution
uh so so they're in the
right all right let's be clear here
these aren't just kind words uh for a
fellow Governor these 25 States they're
offering Manpower they're offering
security they're offering real support
Blue State Governors whine and complain
beg for more Federal money you know
Republican Governors they want to take
action and enforce the law so is
Republican Congressman by the way Mike
Collins this week announcing legislation
that would prohibit Federal officials
from removing barriers at the border but
according to msdnc host Joy Reed
protecting the border is racist even
comparing support for border security to
Jim Crow era segregation you can't make
this up this is NBC
News this massive resistance it sounds
like the old Southerners who said that
we will resist integration by any means
necessary that chip Roy language how
does that read inside of the Latino
Community will somebody tell joy that
her favorite President Joe Biden once
worked with the former clansmen uh to
stop the integration of public schools
he didn't want them to be racial jungles
she may want to know that uh pretty
delusional otherwise now of course all
of the far-left vitel next year we could
have a commander-in-chief that would
actually restore uh security at our
Southern border on Tru social former
president Trump writing we encourage all
willing states to deploy their guards to
Texas to prevent the entry of illegals
and to remove them uh back across the
border those that Biden has let in
should not get comfortable because they
will not they will be going home now in
the meantime Governor Abbott he's not
backing down every day more law
enforcement more barriers more razor
wire according to Abbott The Showdown W
will not end until our border is secure
all right here's the big question of the
night what's Joey going to do what's is
he going to Pro precipitate a fight
between federal law enforcement and
Texas guard is he going to send troops
to confront the Texas guard hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else